i mean it's just been such an outpouring
of support from them
just hearing about how much the show has
touched their lives
and i think it speaks to the importance
of of stories like kim's and stories
like this
like this movie you know that that we
really do have the ability to
to have a profound impact on the people
who
watch them because there's just so few
like it
out there in this moment in time so you
know obviously very
very shocked very sad very angered um
but also very grateful for for all the
show has given me and also all of the
shows given
so many people all over the world yeah
it's so hot i think i
gotta take my shirt off oh
i see hey what would you suggest to uh
get this blaze under control it's a
little bit unbelievable still for sure
um you know it's been like we shot the
movie over a year
in sydney uh shut down for four months
in the middle because of the epidemic
and uh it's certainly not been an easy
road but
you know obviously been the most
rewarding experience of of my life
i'm so happy that it's you know it's
like lizette was saying we so rarely get
these opportunities where
we get that kind of marvel sized budget
and
you know and there's really only one
marvel out there of its kind and
i really do applaud them for for taking
a chance on
a relative unknown like myself as well